hey guys it is the 24th of October my
name is just this is the games but news
show and we're back with the couch first
up today a new battlefield one update
has arrived and here's what's changed
the object primarily implements a bunch
of bug fixes to both the single and
multiplayer to help remedy various
villages and crashes there's one
particular era which caused incorrect
class ranks to display which has now
been rectified so you may find yourself
at a lower class rank than when you
played before the update if that is the
case you technically haven't lost a rank
it was just previously displaying
incorrectly if you did unlock anything
while mistakenly at a higher rank you
won't lose access to it as a result with
the adjustment you can find the full
patch notes in our story on site
speaking of updates pokemon girl we've
seen quite a few changes today as well
the latest update has added new egg
patterns and notification features among
other things now you'll see different
colored eggs depending on the distance
required to hatch them each pokemons
info screen has been updated to include
pokemon type icons while the game will
also alert you to win the pokemon go
plus battery gets low if you like me
have briefly forgotten what the hell the
pokemon go plus is it's that little
plastic widget that tells you when
Pokemon a nearby just like the
battlefield one patch notes you can
check out the full details of the update
in our story on site the Pokemon go news
doesn't stop there though because an
in-game event for halloween is on the
way between October 26 in November one
you'll find more spooky Pokemon out and
about to like a drowsy ghastly kanga and
haunt up oh and zubat because if there's
one thing Pokemon go really needed it's
more zoo bats it can also earn extra
Pokemon candy during the event so if you
were thinking of diving back in and
now's the best time finally titanfall
super ps4 Pro will not have native 4k
while the game will support Sony's
PlayStation 4 pro it won't be rendering
at native 4k producer drew McCoy told
Ozzy gaming publications survivor it's
not
okay and I'd be surprised if anyone saw
native 4k with triple-a level games
anytime soon it just takes so much
processing power it's unbelievable
amounts of just GPU grunt to do that in
native 4k in September PlayStation
President Andrew house said that the
majority of games from ps4 pro will be
upscaled to call k instead of running
natively at that resolution McCoy added
that the ps4 Pro will allow titanfall 2
to hold its 60 FPS frame rates in North
steadily while achieving a higher
resolution he explained because we also
made the pc version we have some knobs
we can tweak so we just spent some time
making sure it still runs well and looks
good on ps4 pro we should let me know
your thoughts on today's stories head to
gamespot for stories on Hyrule warriors
and watch dogs too and I'll see you
again tomorrow